let's see if we can give ourselves an
intuitive understanding of why the
current account balance and the capital
account balance nets out and over here i
have simplified versions of the current
account and the capital account for the
u.s in 2007. we'll just go line by line
and think about what this is saying and
just also think about big picture in
terms of the actual transfer of u.s
dollars so first right over here on the
current account we see that we have a
balance of trade or we have a trade
deficit right over here the u.s is
importing much more than it is exporting
and so off a net basis you're importing
a bunch of stuff you have to pay the
foreigners for the stuff you imported
and so you have an outflow of funds and
this dominates the current account right
here it's the it's the great majority of
the current account balance this right
over here this 95.7 billion this tells
us that in that year in 2007 you
americans got 95.6 billion more in
income from assets that they owned
abroad then foreigners got an income
that they had from u.s assets so this
was an inflow of funds from that a net
inflow from that income but then the us
gave away more than that to the rest of
the world this could be foreign aid from
the u.s government or it could just be
american citizens
sending payments to their family members
in other parts of the country or also
doing some type of a donation for some
type of aid program or whatever else but
we see that the balance of trade is
really what's dominating so one kind of
if you really were to look at the
current account into very rough terms
especially if you were to focus on the
balance of trade
we see what's happening is what's coming
to the u.s and so let me write over here
this is the u.s and right over here let
me write rest
rest of
rest of world so the u.s for the most
part the story that this is telling us
is that the us is getting
the us is getting a bunch of stuff and
then it's get it's paying for that stuff
and then also giving away a little bit
more than that
and so
what the rest of the world is getting
the rest of the world is getting
is 700 is net
710.8 billion in u.s currency
so 710.8
billion times
so in
u.s currency
but we know that that's not the entire
picture we also have the change in
ownership of assets and so what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to func
i'm just going to focus on the top two
lines of the capital count right over
here which focuses on change foreign
purchases of u.s assets and u.s
purchases of foreign assets and
oftentimes when people talk about the
capital count they're really just
talking about these two lines although
the technically the capital count is all
three of these lines and the way some
people differentiate it this is kind of
the narrow definition of the capital
account and then the broader definition
of the capital account would be all
three of these lines but let's just
focus on these two lines right over here
the foreign purchases of u.s assets and
the u.s purchases of foreign assets so
we see that the foreigners are buying
many more u.s assets than americans are
buying abroad but we could actually net
it out and let's get our calculator to
do it so if we net it out
so foreigners are buying 2 trillion
worth of u.s assets so that's an inflow
they have to pay us dollars to buy our
real estate and our stocks and whatever
else but then you americans are going
out there and they're using those
dollars and they're converting it to
foreign currency and they're buying
other foreigners assets as well to a
true to tune of about 1.3 trillion so
that's an outflow so let's subtract that
out one two eight nine
point five so if we just net out these
two these first two lines
we have
768.2 billion so one way you could view
this if you were to net this out on a
net basis foreigners are buying
768.2 billion of u.s assets so let me
write it this way so
so let me so foreigners are getting u.s
assets
u.s
assets and in exchange americans
americans are getting what was that
768.2
billion
of currency now this is an interesting
thing
americans are shipping this currency
abroad to buy mainly stuff some of it's
kind of a giveaway but mainly to buy
stuff 710.8 billion
but more than that is coming back for
foreigners buying us assets and so it
leads to an interesting question how is
this possible how is more coming in than
going out and the only way that this is
possible that foreigners are able to
ship more dollars to us than we're
shipping to the rest of the world if
this is if the foreigners had a pile of
currency to begin with so if they had a
pile of currency to begin with so let's
say that they have this in their central
bank so they have a pile of u.s dollar
reserves and i won't well maybe we'll
have time to go into the details but you
can imagine there's a pile of of of
dollar dollar currency in the rest of
the world and the only way that they're
going to be able to ship us more dollars
and we've shipped to them is this if
they dig into their reserves of u.s
currency and how much are they going to
have to dig into the reserves what's
just going to be the difference between
this two let's see how much they have to
dig into it so we are sending
this is how much they are this is how
much they're shipping to us we're
shipping back to them mainly because of
the balance of trade but in general
because of the current account deficit
710.8 billion
and so that leaves there's 57.4 billion
that's not accounted for by what we're
shipping to them so essentially they're
going to have to dig into their reserves
by 57.4 billion to make up the
difference and that's what we have right
over here the foreigners reserves are
going to have to go down by
57.4 billion so let me write this this
is net let me make it clear this is we
could view this as our net change net
change in official and i'll write here
foreign
foreign foreign reserves and in general
we view this as the central banks of
other governments having to they had
some piles of dollars around
and for whatever reason they decided to
use some of those dollars in foreign
exchange markets mainly probably because
so their own people could go out and buy
u.s assets or to buy u.s things or
transfer money in some way to the u.s
and also we'll go into more detail so it
doesn't affect the exchange rates too
much but this is essentially why these
two things add up any any amount that
these two things don't add up any amount
by which the current account balance and
the narrow definition of the capital
count balance do not add up then that's
going to have to be a change in reserves
there's going to have to be in this case
more net more money u.s dollars are
being sent to the u.s so someone's pile
of u.s dollars someplace in the rest of
the world had to be depleted to the
effect of 57.4
billion dollars in future videos we'll
talk a lot more about about central
banks reserves of dollars and even
interesting things about how george
soros made a lot of money by kind of
gaming that and all the rest